Transcription: Ninon Rauh
Relecteur: eric vautier
Ce soir, je vous invite
à partir en voyage.
En voyage à bord de mon vaisseau,
le spaceship, direction Mars,
avec peut-être une petite escale,
pour se dégourdir les jambes.
Êtes-vous partants ?
Public : Oui !
Après tout, l’exploration fait partie
de notre ADN, à nous, les humains,
depuis la nuit des temps.
De l’homme de Cro-Magnon
jusqu’aux grands navigateurs,
nous cherchons sans cesse
à comprendre, découvrir, explorer
et repousser nos limites.
C’est encore ce qui nous anime au CNES,
à l’agence spatiale française,
où l’une de nos missions est de dénicher,
fédérer, faire grandir cette technologie
permettant l’exploration spatiale
et les vols habités.
Car vous l’avez compris, ce soir,
nous partons dans une terre inconnue.
Une terre assez loin, inexplorée,
mais une zone inconnue,
que l’on connaît déjà
depuis quelques années : la Lune.
La Lune, à la fois lointaine
et difficile d’accès,
mais atteignable
en seulement quelques jours
et à portée de communication.
La Lune, à la fois hostile
et inhospitalière,
avec des températures extrêmes :
- 250 °C, + 120 °C,
des radiations solaires,
des radiations galactiques,
une absence d’atmosphère
et des roches abrasives.
Je m’arrête là, sinon vous n’allez pas
vouloir partir en voyage avec moi.
Mais je vous rassure, notre bon
vieux satellite est bien le terrain idéal
nécessaire pour les ingénieurs
et les scientifiques
qui travaillent
sur la possible vie d’un humain
sur une autre terre que la nôtre.
La Lune préparera l’exploration spatiale,
l’exploration humaine,
de la planète la plus accessible
de notre système solaire : Mars.
Dès lors que l’on veut partir dans
une contrée lointaine en expédition,
il est important de se focaliser,
de se concentrer
sur le strict nécessaire à notre mission.
Dès lors que nous quittons la Terre,
la distance et le coût
pour quitter notre atmosphère,
cette question devient cruciale.
Et je vous rassure,
là où nous allons, on ne pourra compter
ni sur une aide d’urgence,
ni sur un ravitaillement.
Un des enjeux majeurs,
ce sera le poids de notre valise.
Aujourd’hui,
pour envoyer un kilo à bord
de la Station Spatiale Internationale,
il faut compter 10 000, 15 000euros.
Vous voulez aller sur la Lune ?
C'est 40 000.
Pour aller vers Mars,
il faudra multiplier par dix.
Il va peut-être falloir voyager
plutôt léger, voire très très léger.
Les ressources
que nous apporterons depuis la Terre
seront limitées.
Il est important, du coup,
de créer un écosystème
autonome, stable et pérenne,
pour créer ce recyclage.
Dans tout ce que nous allons réaliser,
nous allons mettre au point
des techniques qui vont nous aider
à ce développement.
Aujourd’hui,
c’est tout l’enjeu
des ingénieurs dans le domaine
de l’exploration et des vols habités.
C’est de partir d’un minimum
de ressources que l’on a,
et que l’on apportera depuis la Terre,
de vivre et donc de créer, régénérer,
et utiliser ces ressources,
comme par exemple,
l’eau, l’air et l’énergie.
« Comment faire ? », me direz-vous.
La première chose,
c’est d’observer à la loupe,
de traquer l’ensemble
de ces utilisations, de ces consommations,
de ces ressources si précieuses,
pour savoir si on en a réellement besoin,
et si c’est le cas,
de les économiser au maximum.
La seconde chose, c’est de les étudier
et de mettre au point des technologies
permettant de valoriser chacune
de ces ressources si précieuses.
Je vais prendre quelques exemples
pour illustrer ceci.
Aujourd’hui, sur Terre,
la ressource la plus précieuse,
est-ce que vous savez ce que c’est ?
C’est l’eau, en effet.
Pour l’espace, c’est exactement pareil,
c’est l’eau qui est importante.
Pour l’eau, il va falloir traiter
chaque goutte d’eau
que l’on va consommer et rejeter.
C’est-à-dire qu’il va falloir
réutiliser l’eau qu’il y a
dans notre transpiration, nos urines,
l’eau qu’on aura utilisée pour se laver,
l’eau qui sera présente
également dans les condensats
de notre future station.
Cette problématique, elle est déjà abordée
à bord de
la Station Spatiale Internationale.
Aujourd’hui, un astronaute utilise
3,2 litres d’eau par jour.
Sur ces 3,2 litres d’eau,
vous avez deux litres
qui sont utilisés pour boire.
Ce qui est recommandé
par votre médecin, je crois.
Ensuite, vous avez 500 ml, un demi-litre,
utilisé pour réhydrater la nourriture,
400 ml pour la toilette.
Et le reste, c’est pour la chasse d’eau.
Dans la Station Internationale également,
le recyclage est prédominant.
Le recyclage, il est proche de 95%.
C’est-à-dire que chaque astronaute,
on s’autorise à perdre,
sur ces 3,2 litres d’eau,
seulement 160 ml.
160 ml, c’est la contenance de ce verre.
C’est-à-dire que chaque jour,
pour un astronaute,
on s’autorise à perdre
la contenance de ce verre.
Pour les explorations lointaines,
la Lune, Mars,
prenons quelques marges
pour nos astronautes.
On va prendre seulement
quatre litres d’eau.
Et l’un de nos challenges,
c’est justement d’améliorer ce rendement,
d’améliorer l’efficacité
de notre recyclage en eau,
pour passer de 95 % à 99,5 %.
99,5%, ça correspond à 20 ml.
20 ml, c’est deux cuillères à soupe.
C’est-à-dire que par jour,
on s’autorise à perdre en eau
seulement deux cuillères à soupe.
Revenons maintenant un peu à nos calculs.
On va aller vers Mars.
Notre voyage va durer trois ans.
Neuf mois pour y aller.
Quelques mois pour l'explorer.
Neuf mois pour revenir.
La consommation en eau,
pour ce voyage,
cette expédition de trois ans,
sera seulement de 26 litres d’eau
par astronaute.
À titre de comparaison,
vous connaissez la consommation moyenne
d’un Français par jour, en eau ?
Pour vous aider un petit peu.
Une chasse d’eau : 6 litres.
Vous prenez une douche ?
Pareil : 6 litres par minute.
Ensuite, vous devez ajouter
le linge, la vaisselle, boire.
En tout, à peu près 130 litres d’eau
sont consommés par jour par Français.
130 litres d’eau.
Rendez-vous compte !
Avec cette consommation
quotidienne en eau, par Français,
on serait capable de faire vivre
un équipage de cinq astronautes
pendant trois ans.
Une autre de nos ressources importantes,
pas vraiment sur Terre,
mais surtout dans l’espace, c’est l’air.
On a besoin de respirer.
Pour l’air, il va falloir assainir,
retraiter tout l’air qui sera disponible
à bord de notre vaisseau.
Cette problématique est aussi abordée
à bord de la
Station Spatiale Internationale.
Aujourd’hui, nous régénérons
en dioxygène, le dioxyde de carbone,
à environ 42%.
Pour les explorations lointaines,
il va falloir
perfectionner nos dispositifs
en améliorant le rendement
de nos équipements.
Mais ce ne sera pas suffisant.
Il va aussi falloir fabriquer de l’oxygène
à partir des ressources
que l’on trouvera sur site.
Par exemple :
l’oxygène présent dans les roches,
l’oxygène dans les poches de glace,
si on va sur la Lune.
Et pourquoi pas sur Mars,
étant donné qu’il y a une atmosphère riche
en dioxyde de carbone,
utiliser ce dioxyde de carbone
et le transformer en oxygène.
Vous connaissez Perseverance,
le rover qui est sur Mars actuellement ?
À bord de celui-ci, il y a une expérience.
Une expérience qui s’appelle Moxie,
qui travaille dans ce sens, c’est-à-dire
transformer le CO2 en oxygène.
Par l’intermédiaire de tout cela,
nous serons capables
de nous rapprocher de ces fameux 100%
pour être autonomes sur Mars.
Bon, je ne vais pas
vous parler de l’énergie.
On en a suffisamment parlé
actuellement dans les médias.
Vous vous en doutez,
il va falloir être économe,
efficient en rendement, renouvelable...
Plein de mots qui viennent.
Bon, admettons :
nous avons de l’air, nous avons de l’eau,
nous avons l’énergie pour notre spaceship.
Il va falloir penser
à nourrir nos astronautes,
penser à nourrir nos explorateurs.
Parce que là où nous allons,
on ne pourra pas apporter depuis la Terre
la totalité des aliments
couvrant l’ensemble
des besoins nutritifs de nos astronautes.
Pour cela, il va falloir travailler
sur le cycle du carbone et de l’azote,
pour nourrir nos explorateurs.
Comment faire pousser des plantes,
des légumes, des fruits,
dans des conditions suffisantes
et nécessaires à leur épanouissement,
avec ces conditions limitées ?
Je le rappelle, l’air, l’eau, l’énergie,
on en a très peu à bord de notre vaisseau.
Aujourd’hui,
il y a des expériences
et aussi des cultures,
comme par exemple l’aéroponie,
qui travaillent en cycle fermé,
en environnement contrôlé.
Et on est capable de produire
cinq fois plus par mètre carré
avec seulement 400 fois moins
de litres d’eau qu’une culture classique.
Autre chose à laquelle
il va falloir penser,
c’est la quantité de textile.
Notre voyage n’étant pas naturiste,
il va falloir voyager,
penser à se vêtir
pour les trois ans
à bord de notre vaisseau.
Je rappelle : la machine à laver
ne fait pas partie du voyage,
car trop énergivore
et consommatrice en eau.
Environ 50 litres par cycle.
Alors je ne sais pas vous,
mais moi, quand je pars en vacances,
pour trois semaines à peu près,
j’ai un gros sac et j’ai une limite.
C’est à peu près 23 kilos
si je veux partir en voyage en avion.
Les astronautes, c’est pareil.
Sauf que ce n’est pas 23 kg
pour trois semaines,
c’est 6 kg pour trois ans.
Et je vous rappelle,
les textiles, ce sont les vêtements
et l’ensemble des draps, enfin, tout.
Il va falloir ainsi se contenter de...
un, deux, trois tee-shirts,
quelques sous-vêtements.
Un tee-shirt, comme celui, par exemple.
Quelques sous-vêtements par semaine.
Pendant trois ans.
Comment faire ?
Il existe des axes d’étude,
qui sont l’utilisation de fibres
à partir de sources biodégradables,
l’idée étant de régénérer à l’infini
votre tee-shirt préféré, comme celui-ci,
en le réimprimant en 3D périodiquement.
Pas sûr que ça plaise à nos futurs
explorateurs « fashion victims ».
Mais quand on sait aujourd’hui
que 4 millions de tonnes
de textiles usagés ou neufs
sont jetés en Europe,
il est temps de produire et de créer
des solutions pour faire face
à ce gaspillage vestimentaire.
Maintenant que je vous ai parlé
de tout cela, vous allez me dire :
« Est-ce que notre voyage
est réellement possible ? »
La réponse, elle se construit chaque jour,
avec les acteurs qui sont engagés
dans cette aventure.
Heureusement, les technologies,
les mentalités progressent.
Travaillant dans l’exploration spatiale,
je ne pouvais pas finir sans vous montrer
cette fabuleuse image.
cette image des confins de l’univers,
qui a été prise par le
James Webb Space Telescope.
Quand on observe cette image,
avec cette myriade de galaxies,
on ne peut qu’avoir le tournis.
Et on peut se demander
si en fait, notre voyage
à bord de notre petit vaisseau
à ressources limitées,
qu’est notre planète Terre,
s’il n’a pas déjà commencé.
Saurons-nous avoir
la sagesse et l’intelligence
d’utiliser ici, sur Terre,
nos ressources à leur juste besoin ?
En tout cas,
de par ses recherches sur la vie sobre,
l’exploration spatiale
pourra servir de guide
à notre façon de consommer ici, sur Terre.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)